it's an eight-legged hair-raising
predator and the largest spider in the
world
the Goliath tarantula a full-size adult
has a leg span up to a foot long a
powerful hunter it can kill creatures
bigger than itself it's razor-sharp
fangs measure an inch long and drip with
venom barbed hairs can fire into the air
and strike the eyes skin and throat
under the cover of darkness it waits and
works then strikes when least expected
if a tarantula lands on you what should
you do
should you smash it with your hand roll
around on the ground or do nothing the
correct answer is C do nothing if you
try to smash it the tarantula will
defend itself with its nasty though
non-lethal fight rolling on the ground
in a panic will likely hurt you as much
as the spider but if you do nothing the
tarantula who thinks you're just a big
moving land mass will eventually walk
off to find more stable and safer ground
and that's how you survive an encounter
with a tarantula